[Música]
salud en directo américa y ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida muy buen día los líderes
mundiales decidieron ayer en la
comprendí 6 pasar la deforestación parar
perdón de la deforestación para el año
2030 y una decisión que no sólo tiene
consecuencias mar en el clima sino
también en nuestra salud una decisión
bien ambiciosa también y en verdad
parece lógico pensar que la salud del
planeta también está muy ligada con la
salud de las personas de hecho
recordemos la deforestación la
destrucción de hábitats naturales está
muy vinculada está en el origen de la
crisis sanitaria que estamos viviendo
hoy en día del 19 para hablar de todo
esto y como cada miércoles estamos con
el doctor oscar franco director del
instituto de salud social y preventiva
de la universidad de berna muy buenos
días doctor cuéntenos cómo ha afectado
la deforestación en la posibilidad de
vivir pandemias tanto en el presente
como en el futuro
si esa reforestación esa destrucción de
habitas lo que hace es que se genere una
extinción de especies una movilización
de especies y permite que el contacto
entre humanos y habitas y animales pues
aumente y tenga una mayor exposición a
la que tenía anteriormente
esto se ha visto países como por ejemplo
en uganda donde la destrucción de
bosques y de selva ha hecho que haya más
contacto entre seres humanos y homínidos
con homínidos buscando su sustento o
recursos en plantaciones de comunidades
humanas
ahora doctor le quiero preguntar si
nosotros los humanos tenemos la
responsabilidad de haber generado las
crisis como la que vemos ahora como la
que vivimos lakovic 19
yo creo que es el principal origen en el
marco del como hemos destruido el
planeta con la deforestación la
destrucción de la biodiversidad
también el comercio de especies salvajes
para consumo que muchas veces son
animales que son huéspedes de
microorganismos que pueden pasar a seres
humanos y también la minería no
sostenible y agresiva que haya destruido
los ecosistemas entonces yo creo que
seguimos destruyendo un balance muy
delicado que existe entre nosotros como
huéspedes adicionales de este planeta y
que nos hace mucho más vulnerables a que
estos problemas ocurren estaba hablando
de los animales y el contacto entre
humanos y animales que se puede generar
enfermedades que pasen de los animales a
los humanos se llama zoonosis entonces
yo quería preguntarle si es que ahora
somos más vulnerables ya lo vimos con el
coi 19 ahora somos más vulnerables a que
vuelva a ocurrir que alguna enfermedad
salte del mundo de los animales a los
humanos
si hemos visto la deforestación y la
destrucción del planeta sólo ha
aumentado en los últimos años y durante
la pandemia se vio con imágenes
satelitales que éstos se habían doblado
o quizás haya aumentado aún más en
algunos lugares debido a que los estados
estaban muy ocupados manejando la
pandemia también es posible que después
de un tiempo con la crisis económica que
puede ocurrir después de la pandemia la
situación solamente se vaya a empeorar
entonces lo que estamos viendo es
simplemente que la destrucción del
planeta necesita ser para dar lo antes
posible para evitar esas nuevas
pandemias esas nuevas epidemias como las
que hemos vivido y esos casos de eso no
si es que hemos tenido hasta hasta este
momento doctor me pregunto cómo nos
protege nuestra biodiversidad de
posibles nuevas enfermedades
sin la biodiversidad es esenciales si
vemos que algunas especies se van
extinguiendo lo que se debe comúnmente
es que otras especies más comunes como
por ejemplo las ratas o los murciélagos
pueden aumentar y éstas especies suelen
ser huéspedes de enfermedades que pasan
al ser humano de zoonosis entonces es
esencial que los gobiernos que los
estados inviertan en general en mantener
la biodiversidad
300 programas a nivel de las comunidades
rurales de los indígenas también
anticipar que pueden ocurrir y hemos
visto más incendios forestales entonces
cómo manejarlos cómo prevenirlos y
también mejorar lo que es el comercio de
la madera y tratar de hacerlo mucho más
legal y mucho más controlado entonces
básicamente cuidar los ecosistemas
parece que es una manera de prevenir
también futuras crisis no incluso que
nos puede salir más barato que vivir
pandemias de cobain 19no
así es y es que ahora mismo estamos muy
enfocados en encontrar lo que son las
vacunas o medicamentos y eso es normal
porque estamos viviendo una pandemia sin
embargo eso es cómo tratar los síntomas
de la enfermedad y no la raíz en general
de la enfermedad y la raíz de esta
enfermedad de esta crisis que estamos
viviendo es esa salud planetaria que
hemos destruido a través de décadas
sobre utilización de los recursos
naturales entonces es esencial como
individuos como comunidades como países
hacer de la protección y generación de
la biodiversidad una de las principales
más importantes una de las prioridades
más importantes sino la prioridad número
uno claro entonces estaremos muy
pendientes de lo que se está debatiendo
entonces también en la con 26 porque
sabemos que no sólo afecta al clima sino
también va a afectar cómo vivimos cómo
nos enfermamos de que morimos road'
dios mío mar ojalá podemos parar toda
esta crisis climática y no seguir
destruyendo nuestro planeta mar doctor
muchísimas gracias yo